okay good evening ladies and gentlemen i
make that six o'clock um welcome to
tonight's planning meeting uh my name is
councilor peter richards and i will be
chairing tonight's meeting a few
housekeeping to start with um we don't
expect there's to be a fire alarm so if
there is one please if you would follow
us all out of either this door or that
door and we will be meeting at the car
park the main car park next to windmill
pub uh we'll need you all over there so
we can check to make sure everyone has
got out safely um mobile phones if you
could please turn them off at the very
least to silent um i don't mind if you
want to use them uh but if you do use
them i don't want to be disturbing the
meeting so silent at the very least but
preferably off
this meeting is being live broadcast um
and recorded for a future uh meeting so
please do be aware of that it is also a
meeting in public it is not a public
meeting so i'm afraid only those people
that are registered to speak will be
permitted to do so at the appropriate
time i will call you forward to sit at
one of the desks in front of us here um
and let you know how many how much time
you have um when you are done speaking
if you could please use the hand gel and
the desk wipes just to give the desk and
the microphone a quick wipe over um
before you leave that we very much
appreciate it
right let's get some introductions done
shall we so to my far right we have
sophie jarrett who is our committee
services member to my immediate right we
have mason nash our solicitor and our
planners are allison willis joe brooke
and we have richard gardner to my
immediate left who has a small statement
to make
thank you mr chairman i'm the planning
manager for tonight's meeting and my
role is to provide impartial advice and
to assist members in their decision
taking thank you thank you very much
let's get into the meeting agenda so
first of all do we have an apologies
please
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors adam and crump
thank you very much members do we have
any disclosures of interests councillor
mills first please
thanks mr chairman um on item 4 on the
agenda that's uh 21 oblique 036
007 oblique psdi canton high school i
will be speaking on that thank you
and also um
on
item six on the agenda it look at the
state barnes i am known to the applicant
and we did have a telephone conversation
so for transparency um i i'll be
stepping off as well and i'm not voting
on it thank you whatever entering into
the debate
thank you very much um again on the
first item uh application
2103607 psid clinton high school um i'm
going to assume that we've all received
one of these and also an email um from
uh mr david blackhead at weinstein i'm
assuming you've all had that um so
please if we could note that i am
certainly here with note mind i'm going
to assume you all are too
marvelous cancer kendall yeah just one
for me again on clemson high school item
four um
non-punary interest as a former student
of kinds and high a very long long time
ago
marvelous thank you very much anyone
else
no jolly good in that case minutes
everyone happy with the minutes from my
last meeting i'll sign them afterwards
that's a lot of thumbs up and nods
excellent okay
so um
with the applications there's been a
slight rejig so you'll have noticed that
application 2102 176 full has been
withdrawn from the agenda uh we also
have no speakers on our final item which
is 21-0-2-5-5-4
f-u-l berry court farm very court lane
in shots well um
we need to uh propose and second a
delegation so i propose that we delegate
that seconded by cancer kendall could i
please have a show of hands for those in
favor
unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to delegate application twenty
one zero two five five four f ful that
leaves us then with our first item
tonight which is application twenty one
zero three six zero seven psid clinton
high school in kington our presenting
officer allison willis allison over to
you
thank you very much i should also point
out that we did conduct a site visit
yesterday that was um attended by myself
council curtis cancer jennings and
councilman mills for those that weren't
aware
okay um let's call upon our first
speaker on this item who is councillor
david gosling of clinton parish council
good evening councillor
now you have been here before so i think
you know the drill um but
[Laughter]
so you'll have three minutes i'll give
you a 30 second warning um if you stay
seated for questions afterwards button
in the middle will turn your microphone
on whenever you're comfortable and ready
you may begin
right good evening councillors and
officers uh and please can i start up
front by saying how much count the
parish council welcomes this long
overdue investment
both in the school and in our community
sadly i would also like to say that
there has been little or no consultation
on this scheme
and the district council and i were
invited to several presentations but
clearly any of the comments we made have
been ignored and during those
presentations we were also told that the
detail could not be shared with anybody
you'll have received the parish
council's detailed submission because
it's in the offices report and you'll
see regrettably our objections on two
specific aspects so i'd just like to
comment on a few of the statements in
that report from the planning officer
and that have been made this evening
so 14 bus services each day are
confirmed but that's in and out morning
and afternoon that means 56
movements of large single and double
deck buses causing chaos in the village
center with occasional gridlock it's
therefore hardly surprising that we're
worried about more traffic during the
construction phase
can we share the office's confidence
that
appropriate routing for vehicles can be
agreed that minimize disturbance after
consent has been granted if the
developer has so far been unable to
deliver the requested more detailed cmp
and and not yet done so now this isn't
rocket science
up there is a picture with the wording
that was put in by the original
proposed contractors it just very
clearly says no construction traffic
through the village
and it's unambiguous it does not say as
the current cmp does no traffic from
gaydon which will leave drivers
following the sat navs and use the foss
way and enter the village from the west
so it won't achieve what they're trying
to achieve at the very least should you
be minded to recommend grant then a
condition must be written in to ensure
that no traffic of any size associated
with the construction passes through the
centre of the village at any time of the
day
this would also sit comfortably with
concerns that have been expressed by
county highways
right turning to the sports hall the
report states other options for sports
hall location were discounted due to
greater loss of existing sports
facilities during construction
now i'd suggest that such loss would be
temporary whereas the loss of amenity
for residents in shoretakers will be
forever
i don't know about your thoughts but for
me the back of a building is usually the
opposite side of the front
and the front is where the entrance door
is located so on that basis the relevant
part of the guidelines is back to back
and on that basis the building is too
close to shoretakers houses 21 to 25 by
several meters
and that calculation is even more
critical when you look at the uh
supplementary planning document which
also says
separation should be increased by two
meters for every meter difference in
floor level
are you satisfied that the hole does not
give rise to unacceptable harm to the
neighbours immunity
please refer this application back to
the department of education and their
developers thank you
mr gosling thank you very much members
do we have any questions for councillor
gosling please
no uh councillor curtis
thank you chair uh thank you councillor
um
you mentioned the the back to back
separation could you just give a little
more clarity or detail on that please
thank you um
table f1 of the supplementary planning
document um gives various separation
distances um the columns are headed
relationship of new development to
neighbouring properties and in that it
lists other buildings front to front
back to back or back to side
it has been chosen
um i suggest by the planning office's
report
to decide that this building because it
has no windows on the side near the
shoretakers it's a back to side
formation and that then means that only
16 meters separation is required
if you look at back to back
and if the back of the house to the back
of that sports hall minimum separation
for a two and a half story building is
27 meters and as you've already heard
some of those distances are less than 26
meters
thank you
thank you very much any members any
other members have any questions
no council gossip thank you very much
for your contribution this evening so
you're already on to wiping so while
you're doing that i shall call forward
our next speakers who is a mr gary
stevens
mr stevens good evening and welcome
so once again you'll have three minutes
and i'll give you a 30 second warning as
soon as you're set comfortable and ready
to go if you want to press the button in
the middle to turn the microphone on you
may
begin thank you chair uh good evening
committee
uh my name is gary stevens i'm a
chartered town planner and i'm speaking
on behalf of some of the residents of
short acres which as you know other
properties are back onto the western
boundary of the school
the residents are very concerned as to
the impact the sports or will have on
their immunity of their properties
particularly their enjoyment of their
gardens which as you appreciate are very
important to them and to their
well-being
number 25 shaw takers which is the
closest property is occupied by elderly
residents with limited mobility and so
their small garden provides a very
important space for them
these properties have relatively short
gardens which those of you the site
visit would have noted
particularly number 25
and the proposed sports hall will be at
its closest point some 14 meters from
the boundary and as you heard from
officers some 22 meters from the rear
facade of the properties
the officer in their report justifies
the proximity of the sports rule
to the existing properties with
reference to the development
requirements spd and the acceptable
distances between the rear of property
and the side elevation of a two-story or
three-story building or dwelling
however with respect to the officer
that distance would be appropriate when
assessing the distance between two
residential dwellings
however in this context you are
assessing the suitability of the
distance between a dwelling and a sports
hole
which is a significantly greater in size
a conventional dwelling has a side
elevation width of circa 9 meters
this sport source side elevation is in
excess of 45 meters some five times the
width
the conventional dwelling has an eaves
height of five meters
whereas the sports hall is eight point
three meters high stepping up to ten
point eight meters high twice the size
and height
this is the sports are not a
conventional dwelling and so a distance
separation of some 13 or 16 meters
based on the development requirements
spd
is not appropriate to use in the case of
this application
the proposed sports or will have an
overbearing impact on these properties
and have a significant adverse impact on
their many of the properties
particularly in the gardens
finally in trying to alleviate other
impacts on the properties
the sport saw elevation has been decided
designed with no windows or openings on
the elevation that faces the properties
in order to avoid overlooking and any
noise impacts
however in doing so that design only
serves to create a problem with respect
to safety and security
due to a lack of natural surveillance of
the area within the school grounds
and whilst the officer states these
concerns are unquantified
they are readily apparent when viewing
the proposals
in conclusion there uh committee please
they we strongly urge you to refuse plan
permission on the grounds of harm to the
amenity of the properties on shoretakers
including their gardens and request the
applicant go back and reconsider their
plans thank you
which seems that it's dead on three
minutes thank you very much members do
have any questions for mr stevens please
cancel jennix
thank you you mentioned about safety and
surveillance
being an issue
i can't quite see the difference between
how it is right now
and how it would be then because
it's um safety and surveillance will
people could still walk in their nose
and climb over some
would it differ
i think if you say able to refer to the
plans on this on the screen um the
concern we have is that the
the the area to the to the west of the
proposed building
it isn't will not be overlooked as a
consequence of the development so
there's no
uh openings no elevations
uh and no windows overlicking that area
and it creates
quite a narrow
area fairly dark
and
remembering the building is very high
and i suppose at the moment that space
is overlooked by windows from the
existing school
so the concern is that that creates a
a space for congregational any
anticipation behavior which obviously
may impact on the
the properties to the side which you see
a very close to that boundary
okay members do we have any other
questions from mr stevens please
no in that case mr stevens thank you
very much your time contribution
and again while you're very kindly
giving our desk a quick wipe down um i
will call on our next speakers now we
have three speakers uh for under our
applicants and supporters so we have
miss helen bridge head teacher of
clinton's high school if you'd like to
make your way forward uh fran rowley i
believe is agent and chris
trim sorry that can our contractor are
you all coming i believe you're all
coming forward i understood you were
we've put three desks out especially for
you so do please come forward
now
will it just be one of you speaking in
two of you here four questions or are
you going to be splitting your time you
have six minutes
okay are you going to want to have a
three minute warning when we're halfway
through
yeah and helen are you starting
france starting okay marvellous in that
case ron whenever you're ready to go
please do begin if you can press the
button in the middle of the microphone
it will go red
and you're good to go
good evening councillors my name is fran
rowley and i'm agent for the application
here with chris trim from weights
construction
as you will hear from the head teacher
shortly the
condition of the current school
buildings is deficient and unfit for
purpose
the site's redevelopment has been long
awaited and there is a significant
educational need which is now urgent and
pressing
granting planning permission today will
remedy this
if construction can commence in april as
scheduled i've no doubt that by 2025
counting high school will be offering a
teaching and learning environment of
which the district will be proud
its exceptional facilities will be
welcoming and accessible to all pupils
and all of the members of the community
the scheme is expressly intended to
provide a cohesive design which makes
the best of the setting whilst
protecting neighbours and the site's
environmental sensitivities
this principle has undermined
underpinned the design of the sports
block which at the outset took reference
from the council's adopted guidance on
building height orientation and distance
to site boundaries to determine its
position on whether or not its impacts
were likely to be acceptable
whilst we can appreciate that the
outlook for a limited number of
neighbours will be changed we're
confident that their standards of
privacy and natural light will be
sustained and that there will be no
discernible
materials and appropriate controls on
use any residual impacts are within
acceptable limits
we can appreciate that some objectors
would prefer an alternative location for
the sports hall
but as this alternative does not form
part of the proposals and is not now an
option it isn't material to the current
determination
i must urge you today to take a view
based on all the merits of the current
scheme as presented
these proposals deliver an exemplar
sustainable development they utilize
renewable energy
renewable materials and energy efficient
technologies they incorporate
sustainable drainage systems and will be
net zero in operation the significant
new tree ensure planting and the new
wetlands and ponds will deliver a
significant gain in biodiversity value
our proposals for parking and coach
drop-off include ev charging points
wider pavements within the site a
dedicated cycle route they will reduce
the current congestion issues provide
safer pedestrian links and limit the
risk of conflict and accidents
the proposed layout enables continuity
in the school's curriculum and
extracurricular activities throughout
the construction period and ensures out
of use by local activity groups and
resident sports teams will not be
displaced
each of these attributes are significant
and long lasting and when considering
their planning balance against the
objections raised they carry significant
and conclusive weight
as the proposals comprise sustainable
development which is in accordance with
the development plan and with your
councils adopted planning guidance and
that any adverse impacts have been
robustly assessed and mitigated this
planning application should be fully
supported and we ask that you approve it
without delay thank you
is dead on three minutes miss bridge if
you want to carry on
high school currently and the whole
school um community was absolutely
delighted at the news that clinton high
school will be one of the first
benefactors from the new job
programme
a year on we've worked closely with the
dfe and would wait to finalize the plans
that have been submitted before new
throughout its climate stage and as the
current head teacher my name rarity and
concern has been ensuring that the
education of students that comes in high
school is outstanding and that the
building will be future proof for
generations of children across south
oration
in addition in addition trespass and i
are emphatic that the students currently
attending the school will continue to
receive the education that they deserve
through our construction phase
i believe that designs that have been
offered will offer an inspiring
environment in which to learn and which
events will represent the ambition that
staff parents and students have for
school in our communities
over recent years the school has seen a
significant uplift through a window
replacement program internal fire doors
and cosmetic improvements such as new
flooring and refrigeration
a new one for starting planning however
we still have to use buckets to catch
water when it rains heavily there are
also and still window frames that we can
put our fingers through and the
interview building is nearing the end of
its life
the need to improve the plans under star
construction is now urgent
why the waste plans work for the school
they maximise the playing fields behind
the school to the north school they
provide more space for students to
socialize play and the proximity builder
to the school area and is easy for
supervision
in addition the plans allow for
optional spaces available for the
pre-curriculum
we will retain our beautiful row of
protected trees to the south of the
astral turf
aesthetically and that obviously makes
us a beautiful site and the campus
entrance um the entrance to the building
looks like a campus and it gives a real
um mature feel to the building that
students i think
will be really grateful for
the building obviously as friends says
sustainable and his commitment to being
carbon neutral will undoubtedly support
the environment
in keeping with the concerns of the
community and particularly the students
at the school
finally the new build will provide an
exciting menu for local community use in
addition to its primary purpose the
education of young people southwestern
and beyond thank you very much
i was just about to give you a 30-second
warning but there's no need thank you
very much members do we have any
questions for any of the three people
presented in front of us council dixon
festival
thank you
uh miss bridge um
we have a
design
schematic design up there on the on the
screen
is that the best that the school
is able to achieve because obviously
what we have before is
we can't change it
but obviously residents have some
concerns
and when i look at that i just wonder if
you think that that is the best you can
have given the concerns regarding the
location of the sports hall
um
i'm seeing a gap between the main
building and the science block and i'm
just wondering everything could move
slightly to the east
not not the science block not the castle
dixon i'm concerned that you're trying
to change a plan on the fly we have what
is presented in front of us and that's
what we have to make a decision upon
i'm just
i'm wondering what the spec what the gap
is
because the science block is staying
what's the gap between the new proposed
building and the science block that
might be for the agent
no it's
perhaps you can tell us what's there i
think
you did show pictures of it earlier yeah
this this area here i think there's a a
canopy with photovoltaic cells on
can you see here
so here's the new teaching block
here's the existing sports block
which is to be retained and there's a
gap the i think the cat the gap that
councillor dixon was referring to is
this space here
which is has has a
is necessary a circulation route through
the buildings which has got
is shown as having a canopy over it
which will have photovoltaic panels on
the ceiling well guys
my thoughts it's not it's not very big
gap
this is about
yeah based on it was a situation whereby
were the architects able to move
everything sideways or basically because
the science block isn't moving if that
option isn't there
then i can see where we are i think
given what we've got presented in front
of us is what we've got to make a
decision on we need to focus on that
rather than what could be
um council james do you have a point
related to this yes in one of the
earlier photos which we saw it looked
like a bike shed there was a photo in it
oh yeah i i'm so i we're not we can come
back to that i think in a minute
weirdness i'm concerned i potentially
shouldn't have asked allison to do that
i was trying to be helpful we're moving
into questions for officers now which is
not where we're at counselor kendall has
a question for our speakers
thank you part of the question i think
has been answered already um but i will
ask i suppose what level of uh
consultations um
with the local community parish council
i know something happened but i'm not
sure quite how much happened with the
local residents as well as the parish
council
um so there was engagement both with the
ward member and parish council there was
um obviously there was a point when the
scheme was sensitive it was still
evolving it wasn't um prudence put it
into the public domain and discussions
were had with those key members at that
stage
in the build up there was a public
information event before the application
was submitted that was at the school and
the whole um the whole area was
leafleted and invited along to that
there was a dedicated website where
people could make comments and those
were fed back in and in fact the
statement of community engagement that's
formed as part of the planning statement
pulls all that together
and demonstrates how we responded to
that and dealt with it
just go on it's maybe touching a little
bit on the last point but if you don't
like it you can cut me off um just to go
on
when during the design process of this
will any specific site constraints that
led you down the direction of placing
the sports hall in that particular
position
i'm just wondering from a design
perspective yeah absolutely and so as
we're on inside we'll look at all the
site constraints and we'll understand
appraisals on this particular site
obviously there were previous plans for
the site that as a contractor we've
disregarded and started from stage one
in the way that we view the site so yes
in terms of the constraints on the site
they have led to the solution that we've
proposed today
yes in particular with the sports or
location which is clearly different from
previous proposals guessing you're
aiming at trying to mirror the current
configurations to a certain degree is
that correct yeah again touching the
point around continuity of education
there are other ways of solving the
problem but they have implications um
about prior implications thank you okay
that's enough
catholics
and obviously you said there's an
urgency with the building and it's
falling apart as it were
if this was to have to go back to the
drawing board how long would it delay
the project by
depends on the solution um it could be
it could be a year could be two years um
we're working within a brief from our
client as the funders for the department
of education and yeah i think that
it's taken us
almost a year to get to this point
currently through the process we've got
so um so in terms of a different period
of time i couldn't commit now um it
would certainly be at least up to a year
with a thought of a delay to
commencement for us
anyone else got any questions either
council
thank you and
just following from
councillor candles i just wanted to
check um
um
fran
during the consultation not quite sure
with the parish council and residents at
that stage were the full details of
these
the proposal in front of us available
in that consultation
yeah i mean at the um public information
event there were boards that just
displayed all the scheme and the um the
layout the parking every aspect of it
yes and that's subsequent to the event
anybody that had questions we did follow
up as well and provide further
information thanks for clarifying that
thank you anyone else with any questions
before i fire him with
one no um the parish council alluded to
traffic management plans mr truman he's
probably more directed at you this one
um i can see that we've uh within our uh
report there's a suggestion that
delivery for larger vehicles will avoid
the village doesn't prevent them from
going through how are you going to
actively manage that to prevent people
going through no that's fine i think
there's a couple of points of having
double checked our construction movement
plan that was revised submitted as part
of the application where we've
considered alternative routes to the
site i think have tried to make it clear
that we will prevent construction
vehicles coming through the village we
understand the congestion and there are
a number of routes accessing off the m40
that avoid that entirely and after
having some consultation highway to tell
what the most feasible route is but
clearly traffic jams instance we need
more than one option available to us in
terms of our next steps for us with the
construction management plan we've
engaged with a third-party traffic
management company who are currently
drawing up a signage scheme for us that
will direct traffic to and from the
school
and the suitable routes into site
clearly demarcating no access for
construction vehicles um through uh kind
of village site and through gate and off
the unfortunate that route and driving
around the alternative route so there is
a commitment from us to contractor to
take that one step further so that yeah
clearly we're not relying upon
satellites to direct vehicles to the
site and all of our orders and delivery
commitments and booking systems will
have that absolute clarity um that we
will not permit vehicles coming through
that side
margaret we will of course condition a
lot of that as well cancer dixon please
yes sorry chairman but uh will you be
able to monitor that because i'm aware
that there are times when uh contractors
basically uh ignore such uh desires and
wishes
we will do our best um clearly we can't
track every vehicle that comes to sight
but as soon as we're aware that a
particular contractor who is using
delivery company is not following the
rules that are into their their orders
with us as a contractor but we will
addre
thank you very much for your time and
contributions evening if you want to
make your way back we have one final
speaker on this item
bruce castle and mills my passion is
going to be over the second don't
normally have this number of speakers
okay councilman's gonna make your way
forward
you of course do know the drill um five
minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning as soon as you're sat come from
race to go do please begin
could i ask allison to put the
photographs up now please instead you
would
i hope you haven't started yet
[Laughter]
over and out
okay
okay
good evening committee
i'm very supportive of the construction
of the new high school and being an
ex-governor very excited that kaiten
high is one of the 50 schools have been
chosen as a rebuild
however not so excited due to the
positioning of the new sports hall which
will blight the lives of the neighbors
living in short takers who back onto the
school
as you can see by the photographs um
perhaps not through clearly actually
this will be the view that residents
sure take it to be losing and gaining
should this application be granted
you can quite clearly see by the cgi um
how the hall is significantly in the
homes
actually we can't you can see the the
sports hall
uh just on the top left there
the tree in the photo if you can see
that is a good market as the hall will
almost be as tall as that tree
the proposed sighting of the sport hall
has already had a detrimental effect on
the residents of shoretakers and is
causing a great deal of distress which
you've heard already which is inevitably
is affecting the health on the thoughts
of having the metal clad block which
will be just 23 meters away from three
of their homes 33 meters long 10 and a
half meters high and looming over them
like a malevolent presence
i'm sure that you too committee would
object to this lump of a building at the
bottom of your garden
there is another option open to the
developers by sighting the hall at the
rear of the school which incidentally
was the choice of the first developer
which everyone on shoretakers was happy
about this was pointed out to the
members of the planning committee who
attended the site visit
citing the sports hall at the rear of
the school is far more logical and will
also make it easier for the pupils to
access the sports ground the sports
hallwood beyond the grass area which
i've been confidently told by governor
is rarely used as a sports facility
i would suggest that the developers
chose the sighting of this block as it
would be more expensive to place the
sports hall as on the original plans
with no thought for the welfare of the
neighboring residents
as i've said on one of my objections on
page eight of the agenda the developers
will be planting trees to soften the
impact which in my mind is an admission
that sighting of these blocks will be
harmful and overbearing to its
surroundings
also i'm not sure if the developers are
aware but the trees will lose their
leaves in the winter and and in turn
expose proposed block for at least seven
months of the year
the developers developers have said this
after if this application is delayed
kites and high will lose funding this is
absolute nonsense as we did contact
jeremy wright mp who in turn had
assurances from the education minister
and dean sahabi who told jeremy this
would not happen an email was sent to
jeremy to david gosling uh kingston uh
paris council chairman and i quote dear
david just to let you know i've spoken
with the secretary of state and he has
reassured me that the change in the
detail of the planning consent like the
position of this portal would not affect
the dfe's commitment to funding this
project as i would expect regards to
jeremy jeremy right qcmp and it was this
was sent on the 19th of november 2021.
as you can see committee weights are
using scare monitoring tactics we are
told by the developers there'll be no
overlooking on the homes and shoretakers
there's no windows on that side of the
building that's a big deal isn't it also
during the hot weather and despite
whether the hall is air conditioning or
not naturally people want the door to be
left open to give some fresh air which
will inevitably lead to a noise from the
activities in the evenings such as music
blaring out to accompany dance lessons
and disturbing the neighbors on a warm
summer evening there is also the problem
with security as this block will act as
a blind spot to the gardens of
shoretakers
sighting the hall on the original plan
would alleviate all these problems the
residents of shoretakers are very happy
with the present sighting of the
existing hall and school and have lived
alongside quite happily for many years
but are now devastated at the thought of
this proposed new hall dominating their
lives the developers when questioned why
the sports hall cannot be cited at the
rear of the building could not give me a
convincing reason there are of course
letters of support one of which is from
fenny compton one from lighthorn and one
from walsall hardly local you could say
as i have already stated i
enthusiastically support the development
of the new high school but we must also
have in mind the well-being of the
community especially the residents of
shoretakers in summary the proposed site
in the of the sports will blight the
lives of residents in short takers
forever and in my opinion this is bad
planning by the developers the sighting
of the hall would be too overbearing to
its surroundings and the health and the
well-being of the residents and their
views must be respected i ask you not to
grant this application thank you
councilman thank you very much indeed if
you have any questions for our counselor
please
counselor dixon
conservatory or something yeah that is
uh taken from the uh which garden is it
that is number 23. that's number 23. i
assumed it was one of those guards yeah
um
and
my thoughts
uh
around the
is it a question or is it your thoughts
yeah
if it's your thoughts hold it just a
minor adjustment to the sport so it
won't make any difficulty of you will it
a minor adjustment
moving it slightly sideways don't make
it
again it depends on the overbearing look
at the sport so that's what we do need
to make a decision on what's in front of
us now we are not changing an
application on the fly
oh does anyone else have any questions
for councillor mills far away ask you
something
ask me something
you must have something up your sleeve
no
come on it's german you've got to think
yourself i i have something but it's i
don't think we should be asking it no i
was gonna
the
distance to warsaw was what i was going
to ask but i don't think you'll know
that so yeah i think we'll move on um
and that's anyone last last call of
questions no councilor mills thank you
very much you're too kind
right let's move on to uh points of
clarification or any questions you may
have for our officers i'm sure we have a
huge list so who would like to start
nobody councillor curtis
kickoff chair if i may um
also i'm just wondering
looking at these um
back to back side to side front side
front front
measurements i just want
how
so two questions is really one one on
that
how
it's decide you know what criteria are
used to decide
which to use whether it is back to back
back to front side whatever
yes perhaps if you could
answer that first please
does it help if i just clarify that's a
test of the test we're talking about
there is obviously privacy
the test of daylight is the 25 degree
test that you saw so there's two tests
for two different things so the windows
come into play in the privacy tests
which is why you see the table you do
um in the report
um but that's that's all about who can
see what an overlooking and how much
privilege you've got the 25 degree test
which alison's showed a little while ago
that's all about data
so that's the second test that we've
applied and that's also in in the
council's spd what was that but just
just picking up on what you said
just to clarify that
that is primarily relating to housing
developments which has as has been
pointed out
are of a generally smaller scale
than the type of building we're looking
at here
yeah
the privacy issues are still the same
i'm going to rephrase if i may i'm going
to rephrase the question that council
curses are trying to ask is is there any
guidance that um we have that would
apply to sports halls or a similar type
of building so an industrial unit for
example
yes and that that guidance is the 25
degree test because that can apply to
all buildings because it's looking at
daylight it doesn't matter what the
building is what its use is what its
size is
if it's too big it'll breach that line
so that's why that's the more
appropriate test for daylight than the
privacy test which is more about windows
thank you chef my pleasure
counselor and
uh councillor curtis's first question
was the same as mine thank you
okay anyone else got any counsel sorry
council addiction you worthless
uh i think it's one for richard actually
um
overbearing we've obviously got talked
about daylight um and we've talked about
uh
yeah daylight and uh size and the rest
of it but what's
how how would we do to define
overbearing because obviously what we're
looking at here
is a fairly solid wall not too far away
etc i know nobody's guaranteed a view
but
what's the definition of overbearing
you're absolutely right overbearing is
very similar to daylight
in most cases they'll be virtually the
same so
that daylight test you see there will
pick up most overbearing issues i would
say any residual overbearing issues you
you're straining into the territory of
the right to view which obviously you
don't have in planning terms
so residents may well see a new building
there and its size
may not be welcome but it's not this you
don't have a right to review but the
important test is the one about daylight
so that's what you get on a cloudy day
that's what you get all of the time and
that's the test we've applied there
and that would i was just wanting to
pick that what i put on that particular
point in the event that we are minded to
support the officer's recommendation
with the landscaping plan require that
the trees in the landscaping which go
into there are of significant size to be
worthwhile at the outset
um
yeah we have a specification already
which
shows that the hornbeam and the holly
trees that are to be planted range
between five and a half meters to five
and a half to six meters when they're
planted
so
so the hornbeam the ultimate height of
the hornbeam will be about 15 to 20
meters
and the ultimate height of the holly
will be about 10 meters
okay council fleming please
um
i'm mindful of the
the corrections that are going on about
what's relevant to this application and
whatever else was there a negotiation
between the developer and the
planner
on the positioning of this building
because um uh fran rowley said there
were no other options as to where this
could go
um was that a thing that was decided
between planners and developers as to
its current position that's the only
thing i'd like to know
um when the application was first
submitted um before christmas in the
autumn we and we had some pre-app
discussions we
we explored the other options fully
um quite extensively
thank you
okay anyone else got any questions
council foreign
if we were mindful to agree with the
planning officer am i allowed to ask the
condition 24 is talking about hours of
operation
do we have any idea what those would be
or is that something i can't ask at this
point you can ask
um
yes so the hours of operation for
um for the construction traffic no when
when it's open when it's up and running
yes please um so what's proposed is um
i've already had discussions with the
environmental health officer about this
and what she's agreed
um would be acceptable would be from
eight to to half past nine in the
evening monday to friday
and ten till four o'clock in the
afternoon saturday and sunday that as i
understand it from the school that's
kind of in line with what's current
current practice already
thank you for the other other sports
sporting facilities and things
let me just get that right in my head
you said it's eight a.m to 9 30 p.m
yeah monday to friday so i thought you
said eight to 9 30 in the evening that
kind of restricts restricts the school a
little bit but okay 8 a.m to 9 30 pm
monsters
um before i dive in with mine councillor
curtis sorry chad thank you um i'm sure
you'll stop me if i can't ask this but
um alison you just mentioned that all
other options were considered during the
planning stage i just wondered did those
looking at the plans um the
the side
the the buildings that are closest to
yes
the buildings that are
fast going too fast um thank you
brilliant stop there um the buildings
that are closest to
the
the houses there
um
i just wonder
the l shape that we can see on there
yes the lower half nearest number 23
and 25 that is 8.3 meters
can you see my cursor this is like an
intermediate tier yes and that's
eight point three meters and the
if you go immediately north as it were
from from
like a lower tier yes which is 5.3 so
i'm just wondering as
part of the considerations when this was
being
uh put together if you like
could the the 8.3 meter section have
been round the corner
i am going to stop you now um
we are trying to change this on the fly
from the sounds of things
what you're asking isn't what's in front
of us now if you have concerns with
what's in front of us now you need to
find your planning reasons to go against
it and be very clear about those if you
don't have concerns about them now then
we have an officer's recommendation and
we can always go with that but we're not
going to be discussing and debating what
is not what's in front of us i just
wondered if that was a consideration
that was considered is it a
consideration for you now i'm afraid
it's not what's in front of you is for
consideration now
i'm going to ask my question um the
traffic management plan i think it's
referred to as the cmp for some reason i
can't see that being conditioned am i
missing something
it is on there but um actually if you
look at the update sheet as well i'm
looking at the update
um
we received a revised construction
management plan
which we went out to consultation
on and last week the highways authority
have
responded with no objection
i've got that could you tell me which
number
on our conditions the cmp isn't trying
to construct a statement that's just
part of the construction method
statement rather than construction
management plan they're all
combined into the same thing yeah it's
the same thing it's just a different she
wanted to make sure don't want to miss
it off
just how it's titled differently
understood thank you
right before we move to debate has
anyone else got any points clarification
i want to make it or ask i should say
no in that case let's get into the
debate who would like to kick us off
counselor kendall please
right okay thank you chairman um look i
think we've gone around this one quite a
lot
i always think it's a shame when you
know you can't get
obviously in a perfect world it would be
great if you could get the residence
parish council
in this case the school to always agree
on on something and that in a perfect
world would be exactly where i think
that's
i think
that statement is reflected in what
people have said around the table
tonight
we can't redesign what's before us
tonight and the chairman's quite correct
on that
and i think i'm gonna have to consign
that to perfect world territory if it
was a perfect world we could get every
round table maybe thrash out a different
agreement that's not where we are okay
so
i'll put that to one side as far as i
can see this is a very on the whole a
very well designed plan
i cannot see any
sound planning reasons to go against the
officer's
recommendation so with that in mind i'm
happy to propose with grant
kansas kendall thank you very much casa
jennings next
um
i was going to say virtually the same
thing
there all these big planning
applications there they're balancing
acts and there's going to be
uh
pros and cons to everything i mean uh
i've seen when i went round the school
yesterday i've seen saw the
the new science block um absolutely
amazing i i love the design of this
school i think it's i think it look it
looks absolutely great
um i think it's
the the people especially the students
of kyneton to have a school like this i
think is absolutely wonderful um i have
no hesitation in seconding this motion
marvelous thank you very much would
anyone else like to speak
cancer dixon
thank you chairman
uh
unfortunately i'm going to say i do tend
to agree with my two colleagues which
before us we can't really make many
changes
but if
this is agreed this evening
and the developers subsequently think
that they could actually
narrow the gap between the proposed
school building and the science block
move everything about 10 feet in one
direction
thus
relieving it nicely that would be a nice
amendment that the applicants could come
forward with if and when it is agreed
other than that
i'll have to support the recommendation
thank you councillor dixon
anyone
else uh i'll just say i i wholeheartedly
agree with uh what council kendall has
said and of course council jennings as
well
we have gone around this and been very
thorough uh in our deliberations and
debates tonight and we've listened very
carefully to what's been said
um
as everyone has heard the the proximity
of the sports block to the houses um uh
along the the streets of the to the west
there um has been considered uh
in every opportunity that we have um
our officers have been very clear about
the
the gaps between those buildings and the
required minimum standards and these are
met
um i can see no planning reasons why we
should or could go against this
we also have to um as is the guidance we
have to give great weight to the
redevelopment of schools and when
considering them both together in
planning balance i'm going to put my
favor inside of the school i'm afraid so
we have given it every consideration we
have listened to what's been said but i
think uh i'm minded to uh to go with
grant as well
so unless anyone else have anything i
want to say we have a proposal it has
been seconded that is to grant in line
with the officer's recommendation and
the update sheet could i please have a
show of hands for all those in favor
that is unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to grant application 2103 607
psid in line with officer recommendation
and the update sheet
right let's move on to our next and
final item of the evening which is
application 2103 592 ful that is idlic
estate barnes in ellicott our presenting
officer is joe brooke and as soon as you
are comfortable and set up joe you may
begin
okay members can i members council dixon
council curtis i forgot to have your
attention now
uh joe is about to begin this
presentation so um uh item uh sorry
application reference 2103 592 full
educated state barnes joe over to you
joe thank you very much indeed let's
call upon our first speaker on this item
who is our applicant mr truman if you'd
like to make your way forward mr trim
good evening and welcome
so you have three minutes um i will ask
you to press the button in the middle of
your microphone and then it should go
red so that'll turn you on and as soon
as you're ready you can start i'll give
you a 30 second one before your timer's
up so whenever you're ready please do
press the button and begin
good evening all my name is richard
truman
class q prior approval to change the use
of barn c at idlica estate barns to
three houses was obtained by the farmer
in 2019.
i purchased bonzi in 2021
and obtained planning permission to
change the layout to two houses and
build a detached garage
one of these houses is going to be my
family home and i have invested heavily
in achieving my dream of living at the
curtin state barns
adjacent bonds also have permission for
residential development
the resultant enclave of four houses
concrete removal
new landscaping biodiversity enhancement
will be an asset to the parish
i began the construction of barn c in
august 2021
in good faith and relying on the farmers
structure report
which was approved by the council
according to the structural report parts
of the timber frame required repair or
renewal
however as the conversion progressed the
scale of wood decay became more apparent
after i removed the asbestos roof sheets
and began repairing the timber frame the
structure became very unstable and hence
very dangerous
my builder advised that i dismantle most
of the timber frame and carry out
repairs at ground level
having taken advice from the planning
officer i have applied for planning
permission to do just that
my application includes a construction
methodology that sets out how the timber
frame will be repaired and reassembled
other than the damaged elements
identified by the structural report all
of the original elements of barn c will
be incorporated into the approved
dwellings
to put this into context of the original
112 purlins
only six require repair and two require
renewal the rest will be reused
when complete the development will
accord with the approved plans for the
barn conversion
given the unforeseen instability of the
timber frame the construction
methodology is the best i can do in the
circumstances
i'm grateful for the support i have
received from the local community
i am concerned about the fate of the
adjacent barn conversions if living
alongside an unfinished construction
site in perpetuity
therefore i ask that you grant planning
permission so that i can complete the
project i began in august 2021
thank you
thank you very much mr truman members do
we have any questions mr truman please
counselor jennings
how much advice did you seek before you
actually took the whole lot down
um
well not not a great deal it was almost
a spur of the moment telephone
conversation with my contractor and his
subcontractors on site he he advised me
that it was precarious
and extremely dangerous
so i noticed that there were con
concrete blocks on the side and they've
all gone as well
when you when you say concrete blocks do
you mean the original fabrication of the
external walls
yes
yes those concrete blocks that that's
right that they they have gone but that
was part of my full planning permission
to remove the walls and rebuild them
okay does anyone else have any questions
they would like to ask
did you obtain a new structural
report
from your builder when he advised you to
take the thing down no
um given
given you've suggested i think you said
there's 112 per inch that's right 112
minutes needed repair you need to
renewal yeah
that seems quite a small amount to
remove the whole building what else
needed to be done what else was unsafe
well when
when we removed
the item the item that was clearly
damaged and it shows in the structural
report photographs there is a member of
one of the trusses which is it is
severed from
its continuation
um and that was where we started work so
to get to the truss to remove it to
repair it we removed the purlins above
it
at that time the structure moved
and it was only about an hour or so
later that the contractors found the
reason why and it was that one of the
upright columns in fact it was the
second one along in that picture
had moved from vertical
and that that then caused all manner of
problems
throughout the building
okay
thank you very much um members do we
have any other questions for mr truman
please
no in that case mr truman thank you very
much for your time contributions even
while you are very finally giving our
desk a quick wipe down um i will call
forward our final speaker of this
evening who is councillor pennant
o'donnell good evening council o'donnell
glad you could make it
you have five minutes
um whenever you're set i'll give you a
30 second warning of course whenever
you're set and comfortable ready to go
do you press your button and begin
well good evening um members
so idliket is one of the hidden jewels
in the eddington ward and for those of
you who've done the award
the site visit aren't those views
absolutely breathtaking they really are
i mentioned this because when we're
looking at this case this unfortunate
case this evening it's all about how we
view it
i mean as ward member i do support
the applicant
because i can also understand the
concern of the planning officers by
recommending refusal of this application
and i can see why because after all
building new houses in the open
countryside is contrary to planning
policy
but on many occasions this council has
granted planning commission for the
demolition of an agricultural building
and the erection of new houses given the
full back position of class q prior
approval for example farmington court in
wells born in 2016 sanborn lane farm in
sanborn june 2019 got high close farm
snitterfield september 2020 and finally
college farm barely in december 2020.
the approval of this application is
consistent with those decisions and core
strategy policy cs20 and nppf paragraphs
79 and 80.
furthermore the circumstance of this
case are unusual but a grant of planning
permission will not create an
undesirable precedent for the district
bonsie is subject to prior approval for
change of use to three houses ambassador
was bought by the applicant in good
faith to create his family home with the
benefit of this prior approval he was
then granted full planning permission
for change of use of barnes sea to two
houses and a new garage
before starting work if planning
permission had been submitted to
demolish the barn and replace it with
the house permission possibly would have
been granted like the examples i've
given above
instead the applicant preferred to
implement the bond conversion as granted
he began work but encountered as you've
heard wood decay not identified by the
original structural report
as you've also heard the building became
unstable and was largely dismantled but
these dismantled materials have been
stored and will be repaired and
reassembled so that the finished
building will be completed in accordance
to the approved plans and i do have
sympathy with the unfortunate
predicament faced by this applicant
i have carefully considered the plans as
i'm sure you have and read the
applicant's construction methodology and
it will ensure the reassembly of the
building using original materials is
carried out importantly with integrity
furthermore bansi sits at the center of
a group of buildings on the idlicate
estate barns with permission to become
four houses it is important that the
reassembly and conversion of barn c to
two houses takes place so that the whole
project is successfully completed
otherwise the incomplete state of bhansi
will simply become an eyesore
in conclusion the completion of all the
barns at illiquid estate bars to four
houses will benefit the parish the homes
will sustain the rural community and the
associated removal of concrete new
landscaping will only enhance the
environment
compared to the fallback position of
class q prior approval there'll be no
net increase in the number of houses and
there are several letters as you'll have
seen of support and no objections from
the local community and i fully support
the reassembly of barnes sea as set out
in the construction methodology
so i ask you to view this unusual case
with a logical viewpoint and a grant
planning permission thank you
thank you donald thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
ward member council jennings
good evening councillor uh obviously you
mentioned lots of examples uh that's
great um
but obviously none of those have
had their
bonds demolished prior to actually
getting planning application
um
well i'm presuming that and i haven't
looked into all of those examples but
i'm sure do you have sir i have no
you're right yeah
and
with the parish council i know obviously
you're not the parish council but
obviously therefore i won't be answering
on their behalf but they have not
objected to it is my understanding okay
that's great
i don't think that's a lot of
questioning you were going down but i
won't be asked on behalf of the parish
meeting
do you have any other questions
no okay in that case council penalty
thank you very much indeed for your time
contribution
okay let's move into points
clarification for our officers do we
have any questions for our officer
please
anyone
council had your seraphim nothing had a
hand up there
i thought just about time i spoke up
um
this has been a case for a long time
hasn't it if a building is
demolished completely
then planning you can't get planning
again
but surely we we've seen pictures of
this building recently
and it's not going over the footprint
the new building is not going over the
footprint of the existing
what was the existing
um
well i think
anything would benefit looking better
than what's already there
so is there any special circumstances on
on that
um i think it's for you to determine
what those special circumstances might
be uh we're looking for points for
clarification
um do you have a specific point of
clarification
well it's
basically it the building's been
demolished
so normally as far as i understand it
over the years that
you can't give planning permission for a
building if there's nothing there
i think yeah i think there's point
clarification here and that would be
um
the conversion policies of this plan and
all previous plans and the permitted
development allowed by class q and other
classes is always founded on the
existence of an existing building that
can be converted
in this case that building no longer
exists so that fallback doesn't exist so
it is
as simple as saying it is a new bill
dwelling in the countryside
council jennings
i'm presuming whenever with the class
two conversions that i mean they happen
all the time they start on them and then
all of a sudden they discover that
half the wood's rotten or
how do the
how how do you actually go about
rectifying that in a in a planning
manner did you put in a new application
or
that's the sort of thing that's picked
up by the structural survey now i can't
answer why it wasn't picked up this time
but those are the sort of things that a
qualified surveyor would go in and look
at and if there's remedial work that
would be apparent at that stage and we'd
know about it so we'd know the extent of
fabric that would have to change so we
could take a view
proportionately
as to how much is conversion and how
much is new build because at some point
you reach a tipping point and it becomes
a new build that's why we need to know
how much is happening and in this case
it's obviously gone beyond that it's
gone 100 beyond that because it's gone
all together
so that what i'm saying is the
structural surveys are
is the way we have an understanding of
what level of conversions required
yes if that were to change um in any way
we you would need to submit a further
application with a different structural
survey and a different plan in terms of
perhaps if new members needed to change
or new walls needed to change as a
result of that exploratory work and we'd
reassess it and we may or may not grant
permission dependent on the level of
conversion that's now needed
okay thank you for the clarification
council dixon next please
thank you chairman
richard is there anything in planning
which allows for properties not to be
new builds but rebuilds
because essentially what we've been
proposed here i think is using the
mostly probably possibly even 90
of the materials that were there prior
to
it yeah it's it's effectively a
facsimile of what was there before
in many ways um
but it's nonetheless a new build in
planning terms because it it's gone and
you've started again
um so it can't benefit from conversion
policy and it can't benefit from class
qpd rights
council curses please
it was pretty much the same question i
was just wondering yes does the
does the re does the use
in the re in the reconstruction of the
existing material have any material
but i think you've answered that already
richard really
it it does on our balance because it
means it has less impact that's why
there's no you won't see a reason for
refusal on landscape grounds or design
grounds because in that respect it's no
different from what happened before it's
the principle of yeah that understands
the issue yeah thank you
cancer candle next please thank you
chairman
okay
forewarning this could be a slightly
complicated muddled points of
clarification but i'm struggling with
this one
um so try and help me uh we've got an
application site where
the applicant for whatever reason no
offense whether you acted quickly or too
quickly and demolishing what was there
the the buildings
with the class q qualifications have all
fallen down effectively all were held
i i understand your point this planning
system isn't there to find a way forward
that the free market is there to find
that way forward we can accommodate it
as far as we can but sometimes we can go
no further and this is one of those
cases
there may be other buildings that
acceptable there but as the report says
housing isn't if it's in the new build
category not conversion
i think you've answered i think you've
gave me my way forward if i can follow
on from that slightly is this not a
question of a retrospective demo
demolition of and reinstatement of
existing building as a result of safety
concerns now
i use that slightly lightly because
i've no reason to disbelieve what has
been put in front of us but we have no
clear evidence
that there was a structural issue
but is this not a question of being
retrospective demolition and rebuild
the application is part retrospective
because in the description that the
demolition or the disassembly is in
there so the permission is already part
implemented so it's part retrospective
so if members were to grant it
um
there would be no three-year condition
because they've already started it
okay
i'm going to start debating with you in
a minute and i'm i shouldn't be doing
that yet um before you come in uh
councillor foreman first please i was
just going to very far on from what
cancer um kendall was saying is the no
way that we can allow for the fact that
structure was deemed to be unsafe and so
therefore had to be taken down that was
the advice that he was given by the it's
probably following on when you may have
already answered that but
that was the advice he was given by
this con the engineers
you possibly could but we haven't had a
report to that effect so we don't know
the details of why it had to be taken
down
i don't doubt something happened but we
don't know the extent of what in order
to weigh that in the balance
even if it had to be taken down my
concern would be it would undermine
conversion and class q more generally
if the structural survey that they're
all founded on could be readily changed
at a future date
castle
to continue clutching at straws on this
one then
um
if we were to regard this okay uh well
we have to as a new build could we
regard it as limited infill between the
two barns
yeah it's the limited infill test
applies in green belt outside a green
belt you're in cs15 territory so it's uh
it's within villages nearby i tried you
can use that phrase but it doesn't give
you any help i think is the answer
um
council foreign sorry we couldn't go
down the route of special circumstances
also greenbelt i mean you can you can
come up with some special circumstances
but
if you think they outweigh
the planning harm that's been identified
by the officer
that's where they apply
consensus seraphim
special circumstance
new build
would be vastly improved than what was
there
let's let's save that for debate shall
we um does anyone else want to ask
anything of our officers
no uh we'll assume therefore that
councilman sarafin started a debate with
his special circumstance would anyone
else like to contribute towards the
debate
that's genics
you just got to remember that they're
really strict planning rules especially
with class q
um
and i think we're all struggling to try
and find a reason but we're going to
have to
come up with something good
yeah um i'm going to chuck my two
pennies worth normally i'd wait for
everyone else but i think i'm going to
help guide people along a little bit
um i think it's fair to say that we're
all looking for
reasonable justification to put this
through the the trouble we have
is that an application was made under
class q as listed in our office's report
that class q
uh
application was presented with a
structural report that showed that this
building could be
uh
reconditioned essentially that the
structure was sound
we haven't got
a report to say that that changed that
position changed
and whilst we have no reason to
to
uh not believe what we're told
if we were just to take it as read with
no evidence
the same would be true for all future
applications and that just complete and
makes a complete mockery of the class q
which is a national designation it's not
our local one
so we have to be very mindful of that
i'm concerned and this is a personal
opinion i'm concerned that the applicant
has been ill-advised by someone along
the way through this project
that structural report should have been
done
before everything got taken down so that
could then demonstrate the safety
concerns and therefore we would have
something to get our tea stuck into now
but we don't have that
and on that basis and for those reasons
i'm going to propose that we refuse in
line with the office of recommendation
and i have every sympathy with our
applicant
i don't want to do that but that is
the position we find ourselves in
would anyone else like to contribute at
this point i've got
had to serve and first i just asked the
question then
um
there would be a new planning
application having to be put in
if
the client wanted to build this uh
dwelling
if
um
if the applicant wants to build what he
is originally signed up to i guess under
the class queue
because there is no building there yes a
new application
and if we refuse tonight yes a new
application would have to be presented
ultimately what we're being asked to
decide upon now is that application
so if we were if we are minds to refuse
tonight uh a new application would have
to be presented and
and and it would go through the due
process once again okay thank you
councillor ken thank you uh chairman i
think this is exactly the point uh and
it's just sort of highlighting what
we're saying here
if we were to i know what we all want to
do we want to make everything okay for
the applicant we all have a lot of
sympathy for the way this has happened
to you and don't think that we we don't
we we understand that you've been put in
a really tricky situation here but the
thing the point you've made is correct
if we were to go against the officer's
recommendation and grant this tonight
because this application is all built on
the uh class q qualifications we would
be opening ourselves up to all sorts of
problems down the line because we'd be
damaging effectively a national policy
and i can't go along with that if there
was another application that came along
that was sort of explained that this was
you know and you built building in the
open countryside it would still come
with a
section of site history that would be
very relevant to that new application
that would explain how
that new application has been arrived at
and i'm sure that would inform people's
you know understanding of that new
application
but as things stand with this
application before us tonight i just
don't see how we can go along with it so
for everything we've said and everything
people said around the table i'm happy
to second your application
your proposal so
sadly it's not my application but
thank you for the second of my proposal
uh councillor jennings please
i was just going to do i was going to
say exactly the same thing i guess i
have a lot of sympathy for the applicant
um
and regrettably uh
um i think i think everyone here is
going to be
voting the same way but very regrettably
indeed council jackson
chairman
given that we are advised that every
application should be looked at on its
merits
we are basically being fearful here of
setting a precedent which other
few planning applications could as it
were put a coaching horses through and
yet each application should be assessed
on its merits you are quite right each
application should be assessed on its
merits and the evidence that is placed
in front of it
and we don't have the evidence to
support the position that is being put
that is a clear distinction
yeah we don't have any
would anyone else like to contribute to
all debate before we move to a vote
no in that case the uh the proposal has
been seconded is to refuse planning
application for uh refuse planning
application reference 21 0 3 5
fuel for the reasons outlined in the
officer's report but please have a show
of hands for those in favor of refusal
two three four and those against
and abstentions
that's
five abstentions so therefore committee
resolves to refuse application twenty
one zero three five nine two full in
line with the officer's recommendations
do we have any urgent business
we do not in that case ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls oh hang on
uh under urgent business you can yeah
absolutely
um
you do a little free yeah okay but just
to confirm um councillors
the application that
came to uh committee in september
with regard to sm51 napton uh we uh on
the committee decided to refer to the
secretary of state if the objection was
not withdrawn well i can advise that the
objection
was now withdrawn so we can now confirm
it as a council instead of sending it to
the secretary of state
lovely that doesn't need to come back
through us that is that's just
that was the footpath one wasn't it
lovely stuff okay uh there have been no
urgent business ladies and gents boys
and girls thank you so much for your
time contributions this evening and we
will see you next week meeting is now
closed
you